nous sommes actuellement à orphin
communes touchées par les coupures
d'électricité suite à la tempête et
gabriel deux des câbles de moyenne
tension sont tombés cette nuit les
équipes des dix sont sur place sept
mille deux cents personnes étaient
coupés d'électricité à 4 heures du matin
quelle est la situation à la mi-journée
à la mi journée nous avons dans les
yvelines encore 850 personnes qui sont
privées d'électricité
ce qui veut dire que on a rétabli la
très grande majorité de nos clients
déjà ce matin 75 % des clients étaient
déjà avait retrouvé l'électricité
actuellement de vos employés sont en
train de réparer les deux câbles tombés
cette nuit
quelles sont leurs actions qu'est ce
qu'ils font nos agents sont arrivés sur
place le plus vite possible pour mettre
en sécurité la zone et réparer les
câbles dans les plus brefs délais
avec tout un matériel adapté à cette
situation
et quelle est la durée d'une telle
intervention alors cette intervention
dure en moyenne autour de trois heures
le temps justement de mettre la zone en
sécurité de monter sur les poteaux à
l'échelle afin de reconnecter les câbles
cassé et de remettre le courant pour
l'ensemble des clients concernés est ce
qu'il ya des risques
alors évidemment nous tenons à rappeler
qu'il ne faut absolument pas s'approcher
des câbles électriques tombés au sol
restez bien à distance éloigner vos
enfants de ces câbles nos équipes
arrivent sur place et interviennent le
plus vite possible pour mettre en
sécurité
nos installations et réparer le courant
30 techniciens d'aînés dix sont
actuellement en intervention dans tout
les yvelines le courant devrait être
rétabli d'ici ce soir